nest js is a node.js framework for
building scalable server-side
applications with typescript it provides
a suite of tools that leverage either
fastify or express to facilitate
rapid development and predictable
readable code it supports rest and
graphql apis out of the box or you might
use it to build a full stack application
using the model view controller pattern
similar to frameworks like laravel
or ruby on rails and it contains a ton
of built-in modules to work with
databases
handle security implement streaming and
anything else you can imagine doing in a
server side application
nest has its own very powerful command
line tool and you can scaffold out a new
project with the nest
new command that provides a code base
pre-configured with jest for testing and
set up with typescript to help us write
more readable and reliable code in the
source directory you'll notice a
controller which is a fundamental
building block of the framework
it's responsible for handling incoming
http requests
and returning responses back to the
client to implement a controller simply
add the controller decorator
to a class then inside the class you can
implement methods
and decorate them with http verbs like
git
post patch put etc by default this will
create an http endpoint on the root url
but you can pass a string to the
decorator to
change the route or implement dynamic
route parameters in addition
nest provides other decorators to
control things like the status code and
headers then
in the method itself parameter
decorators can be used to access the
request parameters or body
and finally the return value from the
method is the response body
that gets sent back down to the client
what's awesome about nest
is that you can use the cli to
automatically generate more controllers
to keep your code organized as it grows
in complexity
but there's more to nest than just
controllers a provider is a class that
contains shared logic throughout the
entire application
and can be injected as a dependency
where needed any class with the
injectable decorator can be injected in
the constructor of another class
for example a provider can be
implemented as a guard to handle
role-based user authentication
or it might be implemented as a pipe to
efficiently validate and transform
values in a controller
and lastly we have the module decorator
which allows code to be organized into
smaller chunks
where it can be lazy loaded to run
faster in serverless environments
this has been nest js in 100 seconds if
you want to see more short videos like
this
make sure to hit the like button and
subscribe thanks for watching and i will
see you in the next one